[Music]
what awful shooting occurred yesterday
as you saw in Annapolis Maryland five
employees of Capitol Gazette
communications were murdered apparently
they were victims of a deranged man
who'd had a years-long vendetta and
well-documented vendetta against the
paper we found that out a couple of
hours after the shootings and yet some
people didn't wait that long to blame
the White House for what happened
yesterday you saw it again and again
media figures jumping up and pointing
fingers at President Trump who for the
record was not an Annapolis yesterday
breakfast media White House
correspondent Andrew Feinberg was even
more direct he tweeted this you caused
this mr. president he didn't explain how
Dan bhaji know is a former Secret
Service agent and NRA TV contributor and
he joins us tonight it's a little weird
Dan I kept thinking and this is not a
defense of the president nor is red or
anything like that but it's a defensive
accuracy in the truth these are
reporters journalists and of all people
shouldn't they be waiting for the facts
before rendering judgment and yet they
were they were the quickest to jump in
with the ill-informed
claims yeah Tucker I've never seen
anything like this we were in the most
hostile political environment I've seen
in my you know 40-plus years on the
planet where I've been conscious you
know listen tucker the horrible shooter
that shot up the baseball field in
Alexandria that wasn't Bernie Sanders
fault okay although he was a Sanders
supporter obviously the Sarah Palin
incident with the bull's-eyes over the
target with the lawfulness tree that was
not Sarah Palin's fault okay you know
it's speech is not violence and the
effort by some sadly on the other side
of the aisle to constantly make that
conflation when it comes to
conservatives that we are somehow
responsible that donald trump is
responsible is nothing but trying to get
a hecklers veto over our speech donald
trump is perfectly entitled tucker to be
adversarial and even at times
confrontational with the press if he
feels he's being mistreated how he
chooses to deal with that rhetorically
is up to him but the effort to conflate
that with violence is utterly absurd and
is nothing more than an effort to get a
hecklers veto over our speech
well especially since this Ramos guy
didn't seem particularly political he
was mad at the newspaper because they
wrote a piece about him stalking some
former high school classmate it had
nothing to do with American politics and
the morons immediately start describing
different motives bizarre was